et nous accueillons notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures ce soir alexis vastine
bonsoir
alors alexis vastine
par deux fois jeux olympiques de pékin
en 2008 et à ceux de londres en 2012
vous êtes clairement fait voler votre
victoire par les arbitres
suite à cette deuxième injustice vous
avait sombré dans la dépression et puis
tel rocky vous êtes relevé vous avez
remis les gants vous avez recommencé
l'entraînement
et vous comptez bien devenir enfin
champions olympiques à rio en 2016 faut
dire que c'est votre dernière chance
[Musique]
avec 6 vastine re bonsoir
mu est né le 17 novembre
1986 à pont-audemer dans leur père
employé municipal maire travaille dans
une usine de cartes à puce et il ya avec
vous quatre autres enfants une famille
passionnée de sport à commencer par vos
parents votre mère a pratiqué le
handball à haut niveau et votre père la
boxe professionnelle et vos frères
bossard vote enfin toute la famille et
dont le sport vous enfilez vos premiers
gants de boxe à l'âge de 6 ans c'est ça
alors l'âge normal ces huit ans ou huit
ans l'élégant sont plus gros que votre
tête et quand vous rentrez chez vous en
pleurant vous vous dites quand même que
vous avez envie de gagner quoi parce que
j'avais tellement envie de réussir déjà
mais là je perdais logiquement
à 13 ans vous quittez votre famille pour
le centre sport études de vendôme dans
le loir-et-cher à 14 ans vous êtes déjà
champion de france minimes et à 17 ans
vous êtes champion de france juniors à
19 ans vous êtes médaille d'or aux jeux
de la francophonie
c'est ça alors là vous commencez à rêver
aux jeux olympiques de pékin 2008
et vous vous préparez donc pour les jeux
olympiques c'est effroyable à la
préparation un oui bah de torture ouais
ouais vraiment certaines fois vous
évanouissiez pendant les séances
d'entraînement quoi bah ça c'est avec
les régimes n'allait pas que je faisais
un mètre 84 que je fais actuellement et
mais je faisais 64 kg donc à l'approché
des compétitions tirs sur l'eau est ce
qu'il faut pas faire sur les séances de
pm a donc deux courses à fractionner
d'efforts on perd la tête
il vous arrive de vous faire vomir pour
perdre 100 g avant la pesée afin de me
faisait vomir en 64 kg quand arrivent
les jeux olympiques de pékin en 2008
vous avez 21 ans vous enchaînez les
combats avec brio jusqu'à la demi finale
votre adversaire s'appelle felix diaz
c'est un dominicain d'un mètre 65 très
brouillon et vous êtes évidemment
meilleur que lui lorsqu'il faut savoir
c'est que aux jeux olympiques on cherche
pas le chaos on cherche la touche à fin
du combat vous êtes à dix touchent
chacun est là vingt secondes avant la
fin du combat larbitre vous inflige une
pénalité complètement injustifiée ben
ouais parce que ce que vous étiez
meilleur j'étais meilleur et puis je me
suis donné corps et âme pour 1 kwh
arriver là quelle injustice oui alors à
ce moment-là quand brahim asloum qui a
gagné à sydney s'approche de vous vous
lui dites des années de travail pour une
médaille de bronze médaille de merde
c'est comme si un enfant dit travaille
bien à l'école toute l'année et aura un
cadeau à noël ti à 20 sur 20 toulon et
la fin de la menthe soutient une orange
alors à ce moment là vous pensez arrêté
la boxe et puis de retour en france vous
relativiser un peu évidemment vous êtes
dégoûtés mais vous avez quand même une
médaille et puis les gens dans la rue
ouais alexis bon c'est sympa vous
trouver des sponsors enfin bon vous
avalez un peu la couleuvre vous avez que
21 ans et à ce moment là vous vous dites
je vais remonter la pente inédite à fait
logique ça s'est fait très vite parce
que comme je suis militaire à côté j'ai
remonté à cheval directement parce que
j'ai
j'ai fait les championnats du monde
militaires et vous gagnez j'ai gagné là
vous commencez à vous entraîner pour les
jeux olympiques de londres
or ça recommence à 8 heures par jour à
suez à saigner vous faites des combats
aux quatre coins du monde pour vous
préparer à tous les types d'adversaires
possible et vous les montrer au monde
entier que vous allez mieux qu'une
médaille de bronze bien sûr j'ai pas
être pour moi j'ai pas été jugé c'est ça
qui est frustrant j'ai pas été jugée à
ma juste valeur alors aux jeux
olympiques de londres en 2012
vous avez 25 ans vous êtes au mieux de
votre forme vous passer les premiers
tours sans problème jusqu'au quart de
finale et là à la fin du combat vous
avez six touches de plus que votre
adversaire qui est dépité lui c'est
qu'il a perdu ou vous saute il ya un peu
de joie ce qui est tout à fait normal et
là contre toute attente larbitre soulève
le bras de votre adversaire le
proclamant vainqueur en fait vous aviez
18 touche chacun mais il lui donne
l'avantagé
j'entends dans la salle où comme ça
et je voyais à mon frère qui est en face
dans votre tribune il y avait les
escaliers je vois et une criante
inquiète enfin je lis sur ses gestes et
tous
deux
attendent et ses trucs et ses matchs ou
quoi c'est le maquis les ukrainiens on
nous explique toute la journée à la télé
en ce moment c'est un régime corrompu et
ce qu'il ya la possibilité de corruption
non mais là après ça vous dit c'est
insupportable et ce soit là rien ne peut
vous faire évader de votre cauchemar
ouais parce que j'ai tout donné pour ce
sport j'ai pas fait durant des études
je me suis intéressé à rien d'autre qu'à
ce sport je voulais être un champion et
voilà tout mais
bien le résultat me convient pas c'est
là vous perdez vos sponsors et puis des
potes aussi c'est à dire que y'a que vos
proches qui reste autour de vous la tous
nous disent avant qu'on réussisse ou
comme ça mais on se dit mais non pas moi
et tout mais en fait ouais c'est comme
ça après mes proches m'ont à ma copine
mais mes amis du sport sont toujours ont
toujours été là alors là ce qui est
incroyable c'est que la fédération vous
dit tu as donné une mauvaise image de la
boxe et on vous retire votre licence on
retire pas ma licence mais on m'enlève
de l'insset en fait tu m'avais en
retirer mais z et vous retire quand même
800 euros par mois quoi c'est pas rien
non c'est pas rien donc là vous sombrer
dans la dépression
l'alcool buvait beaucoup je buvais
beaucoup ouais vijay plus goût à rien à
ce moment-là vous laisser un peu aller
quoi moi je pensais des idées sont ré
vais penser à vous suicider à l'époque
je me posais la question comment web
mais je comprends les gens en fait
j'arrive à comprendre les gens qui se
suicident oncle antoine a plus rien mais
je l'aurais pas fait ouais vous allez
voir un psy ouais ça marche bien ouais
ouais mais c'est vrai prem propre psy
c'est moi et la boxe pour l'instant
puisque je me rattache à ça encore en
tous les cas pour commencer à vous
entraîner voile après sept mois de moins
de dérapage enfin je puis vous vous
dites toute façon je sais faire que ça
alors
ouais enfin je pense bah oui je pense
que je peux prendre à faire d'autres
choses
j'ai pris du recul aussi avec ça il ya
eu du beaucoup de mal dans cette
dépression mais aussi des bonnes choses
on faisait déjà grillé deux cartouches
donc pékin et londres il en reste une si
elle est ou 2016 ont d'abord fait les
perdre du poids
vié 15 kilos à perdre vata combien 7,7
ça va
alors vous dites si je gagne médaille
olympique
je fais 50 mille euros quand même c'est
charmant vous dites je vais avec mes
potes et mes proches passer un week-end
au bord de la mer ouais ouais pendant un
week-end un voilà je trouve ça parce que
les plaisirs les plus simples
sont les meilleurs mais j'avais vu aussi
ça on en a des pressions est ce que vous
allez vous raser la barbe si vous gagnez
mais en fait la barbe c'est pas et c'est
la dépression et puis je me suis imposé
enfin je me suis donné un pari c'est
quand je re box la race en tous les cas
pour un mec qui s'est pris des coups
depuis l'âge de 6 ans dans la gueule
vous êtes bien conserver vos dons c'est
les vôtres à part celle là j'ai perdu la
patinoire
alors votre rage de vaincre est intacte
déjà c'est pour ma santé fait que je
reprenne pour retrouver un équilibre et
puis surtout j'ai fait de la peine à mes
proches et quand j'ai commencé à leur
faire de la peine ça m'a
mis du plomb dans la tête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup on vous souhaite le
meilleur on sera là on va bouillir
un appui je sais pas si on te l'a déjà
dit mais si ça marche pas en tout cas je
te souhaite pas tu peux remplacer m
pokora dans robin des bois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu